do you think this life has meaning
what do you think is the meaning of life
i'm sorry i certainly hope it has
meaning i mean um i'm certainly trying
to live mind like it has meaning you
know um uh i really love my life now i
just got back from geneva um i've spent
the summer abroad and in europe and
trying to be in a more civilized place
where you can
enjoy yourself as a responsible adult
and then it allowed me to decompress and
then come back here
the thing about coming back here is that
you have to be ready to fight and i
don't want to fight anymore you know i
just want to be able to help a society
and people uh and so i'll have to like
keep a place in europe to go and
decompress and then come back uh to be
able to tolerate this situation so
um life for me has a lot of meaning i'm
i'm enjoying life
this is like um the the greatest the
best part of my life ever right now at
this moment it's just a joy
but you also enjoy the fight a little
bit or no i don't really i'm tired of
that you know it's like uh
why you
you're trying to i'm trying to help
people to see
how they can be happy
and then people are fighting me on that
i don't want to be happy i want to be
ignorant leave me alone that's what
people are saying
well so what is the source of joy for
you when you decompress
mdma is a source um you know in a
place where you don't have to worry
about laws um that's like europe you can
feel really free yeah heroin can even be
a nice uh
space if i'm in my own head
but with others mdma is great um
so uh but good friends good food um
yeah yeah
family love yeah that's right carl
you're an incredible human being you
really make me think everyone listens to
this um
you're i mean uh i'm really glad you
exist um i know you say you don't like
the fight but i'm really glad you're
fighting the fight because it's gonna
help a lot of people it's gonna help at
the very least
uh
help a lot of people think and challenge
the conventions of the day
and maybe challenge them to find joy
i really appreciate you spending your
valuable time with me this was an
awesome conversation thank you so much
for talking thank you for having me man
you